yeah i'm going to try and get at least
a few if not several stafford gambits
today
and jean paneu hi from bordeaux from
bordeaux
alexa where in the world is bordeaux
brazil oh
it sounds french but i'll trust alexa
thanks for that oh it's france
is it actually france did alexa lie to
me
alexa did you lie to me
i'm not always right but i don't lie
how do i know that's not a lie
alexa how do i know that's not a lie
oh that was a passive aggressive sound
and t gains good luck thanks so much
you just initiated a hype train hype
trains taking place as the tournament's
getting underway i'm gonna play and
chess
i should have prepared three two it's
too late now
just have to mentally prepare oh no i'm
not playing anchov i'm playing
number three that's strange okay uh
london time i'm not black so i can't
play a stafford
but london is also a fun opening
so i'm going to play aggressively um
you might go into a pierce thanks for
the inspiration
eric oh thanks for subbing the fco is
opening prep for this afternoon's
catalan
opening turning interesting
fco i've heard of mco
modern chass openings but fco i haven't
heard of before
okay h6 let's um let's castle queenside
go for the usual g5 is a move
oh that's that's a move scam train hype
yeah it's time to donate all the bits
and all do all the prime subbing
and donating etc
um maybe h4
let's play h4 i was calculating g4
knight h2 h5 knight
f1 to g3
and the light will sit happily
hey thanks for that oh ception gifting
subs
thinks ocception recently
became a sub now spreading the love yeah
there's a lot of people to think i
really appreciate
all the people
but i have to stay focused on the game
this is a nice move because i attack the
pawn i also prevent black from castling
because i win
this thing black defends and counter
attacks
wondering if i can play e5 here
it's an interesting move
it's risky because it might be
overextending like e5 takes takes knight
d5 e4
the knight is trapped in that line let's
do it
oh i blundered you
kind of did i actually i don't know
[Music]
i miscalculated um
i have to improvise
so the the problem is like oh never mind
if knight d5 e4 there's bishop h6
um this is also possible
i think all if you have amazon prime you
have twitch prime
feel free to give subscribe to take the
money straight from jeff bezos
yeah um thanks for making that clear
matt rob 91.
hopefully everyone understands that oh i
lost a pawn
there's crazy move rook f6
which there's some logic to actually
rook f6
um it depends how insane i want to be
no let's play rook d2 and then rook f2
rook d2
or not in this move threatening to take
that's tricky
i'm down about a minute um
yeah i'll try and thank everyone maybe
between games
but uh position's interesting this is a
threat
opponent clearly sees it
oh um
king b1
[Music]
yeah king safety first so black cat
castle
that's a good move probably knight g6
doesn't do anything
[Music]
knight c3 rook da traps my queen
i'm in trouble
i have to play this sad move
yeah this is really sad
it was actually really sad c5 is coming
man
okay let's play let's play tricky chess
i'm going after a6 it's not easy for
black to defend a6
and if a6 falls in maybe b5 can fall
oh the bishop moves backwards what
oh someone okay alexa just told me
something arrived
i don't remember what i ordered oh maybe
i do
okay i'm getting distracted again
oh wait this is really bad
also thanks people for so much hype
i need a miracle here
okay
i'll start pre-moving
can make a past pawn maybe
one's moving slowly
the vienna gambit is a forced win for
white
wow i won that
the clutch h-pawn how did i win that
how did that happen is this real life
it's an early christmas miracle how did
i win that
well the time situation was ridiculous
too
it was 43 sec it was 43
wait move this down a little bit
yeah it was 34 seconds to three seconds
opponent maybe got too complacent i got
completely outplayed
man well that's a start that's a wake-up
call
i guess oh
undefeated i feel so dirty
man but that's why that's one of the
reasons why i don't resign
because sometimes when you're winning
you get a bit more careless than usual
dirty flag bits
it's always the hope of the dirty flag
things double the pawns
yeah and thanks to everyone it was hard
to read off all the names while
almost flagging but i do appreciate
people okay berserk time and staff are
gambit time
or not okay vienna
or nights time yeah center fork trick
time
that's a fun opening a lot of like newer
players will fall into this
and it's not winning material but it
gives black uh
a nice uh nice position
some early momentum
yeah so this is one one of the most
played lines
i'm queen d is usually the way to go
just so i don't
block anything queen's not a target
and black has basically two main
advantages here
is uh the bishop pair and more space
with the pawn on the fifth rank i'm just
realizing i'm i'm allowing this move
or that move i played this with the
intention of
someday castling and then attacking ooh
okay tactics time
yeah very simple removal of the guard
let's castle
i like to play knight d4 next
threatening the queen and threatening a
fork
there's queen d1 or that move
okay
got to take a calc final so i can't
stick around but here are some finals
bits oh
yeah good luck for your your final
keep in mind sleep is important so don't
stay up all night
um eat healthy drink some tea
oh my pawn
someone should call an ambulance but not
for me
okay just have to watch my time
oh let's go also thanks for the hype
choo choo
choo choo something something and
vanguard what's up vanguard
shout out to vanguard this is a kiss of
death
okay so that was a cleaner game than the
first game
i feel like every game will be cleaner
than the first game
oh coffee coffee is greater than tea ooh
so yesterday i set up um
[Music]
i set up one of these
how to explain choo-choo bits
there's a program called amazon
influencers hey it's a rain
nameless bandicoot thanks for reading
if you're just joining i'm playing chess
it's a daily super blitz arena
trying to be aggressive this game i'm
trying to take down the
the london opening hey eric b5 coming
it's the first time i've caught you
streaming
hey oh welcome welcome to twitch
oh i might be getting forked
also might be mating yeah
so i have a i have a funny story about
this exact line
i forgot what year it was but i was
taking a long
international trip and um
i was born on the plane like i didn't
have access to wi-fi
i just had my phone so i just started
playing stockfish
and i played this exact line against
stockfish
i think i as white i played knight c7
took the rook
but i also fell victim to this so it's a
useful
thing to know um if it weren't for
knight e4 i think this line would be
good for white but knight e4 is a strong
counter-attack so that was a nice eight
move win
i feel like i lost track oh yeah thanks
double the pawns for the bits thanks
nameless bandicoot for the raid
haven't heard of that streamer but i'll
have to check you out
hope someone can give a shout out uh
that's berserk again
i'll play e4 this time
so i was going to say um i s i set up
this amazon influencers
like store page thing hi eric i saw your
twitch handle written on the wall of the
96th street subway station
first time catching your stream oh maybe
that's how you discovered me
i'm not sure if i believe that but you
should take a picture then i'll believe
it
anyway i was going to say um i have like
an amazon
type storefront with different
recommendations people can use the
amazon
command for for t recommendations and
for
chessbook recommendations and some more
other stuff
um hopefully it works
but it's it's kind of like this this
thing you have to have a certain amount
of following on social media
love for chess after all these years
oh thank you hartwig
also i'm trapping the night wow
was i i may have missed it
i should have played that a move sooner
actually but
okay it still works out
some weird pawn structure nice being up
a piece
half a year joke time if you forget the
rules to chess
don't worry you're allowed to check uh
haha and occasionally you're allowed to
check mate
thanks for subbing swasmatize for half a
year welcome back
awesome let's develop whoa it's doobie
doo
dooby doo with a thousand bits that's a
new name
i appreciate that thanks for the support
okay all the pawns are tender actually
all the pawns are
attacked more than they're defended this
pawn attacked three times
this pawn attack twice this pawn once so
black defends two but not
three
okay so i'm up a pawn
actually i'm just up a minor piece and
it's almost
mate it's really close to mate
i think um yeah the most efficient way
is bishop c6 here
threatening made in one well i can't
take because it's pinned
yeah life is very good
do i miss maiden one
if something to b7 the king would run
so sometimes it's good to check but
sometimes it's good to not check and
just
try and suffocate the king okay now
we're going to see a flurry of checks
i'm going to win the rook and the end
here we go oh i could castle with almost
checkmate
let's castle king safety first
but more like king unsafety for black
or non-safety
okay so if black didn't have this pawn
this pawn this pawn or this pawn it
would be stalemate
but that wasn't the case
okay so top three
have a nice berserking streak
i've learned scholars mate pinsfox the
word development
but i can't see past my nose and
blunderfist
what next pins forks
development i mean there's more terms
that you can learn
the skewer zwischenzug
zugzwang pork
oh i forgot to berserk okay but i'm
playing a
decent player i'll play queenie too
and yeah this is a
a playable variation
um when you see mate in one look for
better
following the hamilton philosophy i see
oh oh the ham yeah always have to
support the hamilton philosophy
um i'm actually not entirely sure what
to do here
play bishop e2 i'm at castle king sign
and keep it positional
that's a decent move
which way to castle the queen's a little
bit awkward actually
queen g5 what's castle
make black decide what to do oh
it's gonna get sharp and the whole idea
was to um
to trap the bishop if bishop takes d3 i
rook d1
and then it's pin and win
updated upon it ragequit thank you for
the content i just have one question
regarding tea have you ever made your
own chai masala
oh i have not made it from
scratch i've i've had like the
tea like the um
chai tea bags but also chai
i can show one that i i have
to write in this move
i have this thing um it's like nice
powder
matcha chai play rook e1
um you kind of blend it with water and
maybe milk
you can make a latte okay so this
position
i'm technically down material
but it's interesting i'm not sure what
my plan is
harley queen g3 first just aligning with
the king
g7 is a clear target i want to make way
for the pawn
oh i should have seen that coming
maybe it's okay i'll play bishop uh
bishop e5
and then put the rook on d1 if i i lose
a pawn
um
and black's playing this well there's a
cool trick to play bishop c7
rook here and then bishop here
threatening queen b8 and the rook
not sure if it's winning anything might
be winning a pawn in the end
depending where the rook goes
as a cool little geometrical
almost a sideways rectangle
oh bishop d6 i forgot about
um i'm not winning anything i'm probably
losing just my a-pawn
that's unfortunate
oh i'm losing more i'm losing my bishop
oh it's really bad
okay i need a miracle i'm down about a
minute
i have a queen for rook bishop rook and
two pawns
so two rooks of bishop and two pawns man
that's not good
okay i want to put my rook here
this is going to be really tough that's
some queen v8 idea
i'm black's so solid though
i mean the hope is probably dirty
flagging
or mating on g7 someday
some way actually i have a threat but
opponent doesn't allow me okay let's go
for b5
oh that's not good
black has force made in three
but misses it i'll show it after the
game play this move
okay trying to be annoying with my
pieces
now what am i doing
everything's defended for black
i'm getting forked
no my baby
stalemate me please ah that's checkmate
ah
okay my first loss there's a really cool
maid in three actually
i'll just show it um it was
after king g2 so i guess this position
is made in four i'm pretty sure
uh the line is knight e3
forking i'm only legal moves to take and
then
check i have to move here and then mate
so it's a cool
cool pattern opponent played well
i missed this rook d5 move missed a few
moves that game
okay life goes on
stafford gambit time maybe
what are your favorite non-chess books
genres
oh um i've been reading like a lot of
business kind of i love the content
non-fiction
curious what's the hardest concept to
teach intermediate players
oh it really depends on the player it's
hard to generalize among all
intermediate players but usually
if you're intermediate player you have
some weaknesses that need to be
addressed
[Music]
i like malcolm gladwell's books
the art of learning by josh waitzkin
really really good book
hey it's akd it's 500 bits thanks so
much welcome back
so after the tournament i'll have more
more focus and ability to
answer questions in more detail
hopefully
um but opponents applying pressure
let's play let's play bishop b6
i'm trying to be safe
it's not a pleasant position
i think i want to just go for the trade
of of all the rooks
thanks for subbing uh we go and i don't
know
so i put this welcome back
uh it's not an easy position have to
move back i think it would be nice idea
for you to buy eye tracker so that we
could see what pieces you are looking at
and understand your thinking
process better i actually i have an eye
tracker
it's right in front of me i just haven't
used it in a while
but i could use it it's a it's a toby
um that's it's plugged in so i can't
really
stretch it but it's here maybe at some
point
is the point gonna just repeat
i'm not going to repeat okay white's not
either
so
knight uh 95 is kind of interesting
because it just forces a trade of
everything
or maybe not i guess if i could move the
knight somewhere
i was looking at um yeah
takes takes oh i'm losing a pawn
oh but then i win the c2 pawn and i
attack
f2
i think this is a good line for me if
any sort of check i play rook here and
i'm
threatening to take this is threatening
force mate
i think it's over wow
because the threat is takes here here
here here here and then meets
and it's going to happen
yeah i was under pressure like the whole
game
and then because my opponent made
one bad decision
okay that worked out nicely so top ten
thanks for subbing austin numbers
solving for five months
yeah i know there's some like twitch
extension thing
where you can you can let viewers see
the overlay of the eye tracker
um it'll take some
some investigating to set up
ah everyone's declining the stafford and
two staffer gambits just declined
that's so unfortunate
uh let's castle i'll play a bit
differently i played f6 last game
i think this game i'll play h6 just
preventing bishop here
then i can safely put the queen on f6
thank you rob tier subbing with prime
okay okay with the bishop trade and duck
jumper also subbing with prime
appreciate that
i know there's a question what does
berserk do um there's a berserk command
which should answer that
but it gives me extra points also makes
the game sometimes more fun
but also more stressful
okay so this is i guess one of the
benefits of
um the fact that i took on b6
i can swing the rook all the way over
question is maybe queen f4 first
and trying to provoke g3
g3 is weakening to the things that
g2 used to defend
concerning rook h5 rook h5 is kind of
cool
so white wants to like move the knight
and attack my rook but the problem is
the knights pin to
f2 pawn and now i can kind of take
advantage of this pin
it's still tricky though
here because lights no longer pinned i
mean this is a consideration
95
oh my time i forgot i berserked
i was explaining what berserking does
i have no time left i have takes
let's play this move
okay i feel like i get in these
situations a lot
just have to roll with the punches move
quicker
so if the queen moves away from
defending the knight i can take and then
take advantage of the bishop being
overworked
queen here may be expected then i play
bishop here to prepare this
when it's perplexed
i'm looking for ways to really opponent
left the game
maybe the my time management is so
disturbing my opponent couldn't
and bear to look at so little time
i don't know
it's a weird time i mean it's probably
like losing connection or maybe
there's some internet outage or
a pizza delivery man arrives have to
find a tip to give them
i'm gonna claim victory
i could call a draw but no no no wait i
missed it
okay and
i pause there just to make the the
caller draw a comment
and then it went it kind of it faked me
out
hey eric hope you are having a good day
oh
i am thanks for that being 24.
the same wishes to you thanks for
subbing that was a close one
yeah okay moving on
so i have some some points to make up
okay we're gonna have a
london versus caro khan so basically a
slave
play c4 opponents playing a stone wall
i'm going to play the setup with queen
c2 and then probably h3 g4
maybe start with this square is very
nice for the
control of the minor pieces thank you
andis boots
gifting a sub to solo third something
something
i appreciate that
yeah this uh this sort of setup is
really nice
my question is what to do rook g1
a king b1 always play king b1
i mean a3 could come o
maybe king b1 wasn't a good move because
i might be getting forked
let's take here first they make me watch
one ad every month
seems unfair
wait who does oh my position
[Music]
wait this position is unfair
wait i'm getting crushed because knight
c3 i lose exchange
oh i can't even play king a1 because i
think i mated
this is really bad
i'm down on time but it's gonna be a
scramble
i had eggs earlier but they were they
were hard-boiled eggs
they're actually deviled eggs so not
quite scrambled eggs
okay that's a mysterious move
let's control the g file
and position is not bad i don't think
like black missed a chance to win
material
and now i'm up on time
not clear what to do for black if it
takes i
get the diagonal that's probably a good
move let's play this move
i'll take
okay position is very nice now turning
made in one
let's go wow that ended quickly as
black's attack kind of stalled in my
attack
and carried through i am going to say
the same thing every time i resub
really oh i don't think you said that
last time
but maybe this is a start a subbing for
two months
it's gonna feel like deja vu there's a
there's a few people that say something
about deja vu every time they sub
okay no berserking gonna play
i guess no staff or gambit or no luchini
it's pronounced mdpwe because it's based
on french
oh my depuy oh my depuy
interesting
okay yeah i don't really speak french
much
i don't really play the french play this
move
going after the bishop hair it was a
very typical move for these
kind of italian type positions
i had to play queen back oh that's a
move
i wonder if i've walked into some
opening trap
it doesn't seem too bad for me though
i'm gonna retreat my knight eventually
some idea of playing f5 and this is a
nice outpost i probably don't want to
take
these too soon
let's go eric let's go from india oh
thanks for that
justified play this move
oh wait if i play this or takes takes i
get forked i lose a piece
so maybe this move i almost missed that
yeah so i want to play this and not
allow knight g5
there's a cool little trick um queen d7
right here and then if we trade i
i enter meso or as the germans say
suicide on f3 and then take back
not sure if that would be so great for
me though
and it might make more sense to
like just go for f5
i'll probably start with queen d7 then
decide
okay now the queen's defended
i think that was a mouse slip oh but the
heat just came out i'll be right back
yeah not sure if people could hear that
because i have like noise suppression on
but
the heat fan is like right over me so
it's allowed for me okay trying to open
that file
um
i'm gonna play rook f7 going for the
double
up
on the bubble up
it's nice when you double up uh behind
the pawn
but there's tension with between the
pawns so at some point
you can basically choose when the file
opens
um probably right now there's gonna be
tactics takes
should win just have to watch out for
counter tactics
i think it's good for me because if if
takes takes
takes takes takes i have takes i'm in
the pawn in the end
so yeah this pawn was overworked
oh i forgot about that move
i'm not winning anything
that's unfortunate
i have to take debating between
[Music]
king g6
i think king g6 it's so weird
but the king helps defend the pawn it
can't easily be attacked
and now we probably go for a queen trade
also threading a fork there's queen b2
almost 30. oh years old or oh
oh africa for 29 months wow
g4 and we're both trying to attack on
the same side
so it's spicy
maybe this move the c pawn is a
potential target
that king is the king has no squares but
it's so hard for like to check it
not sure the point of that move
i guess defending the pawn but now the
rook's not defended so the pawns pinned
hmm
so i'm bringing up the square oh i'm
logging knight b6 but knight b6 i have
uh queen a7 cool line
um
just gotta move quickly yeah this is
me is this meat it's close to me
there we go yeah so the same idea
existed in the line
if knight b6 uh queen a7
takes and then here and like the better
tries to run
this way
actually maybe
i don't know the checks would continue
for a while
i i don't know what's going on but it
would have been fun
okay that worked out nicely thanks for
subbing
doobie oh dooby doo i cheered a thousand
bits now subbing thanks for that
oh diamond color asking about knight
takes f3
um i'm not sure if i'll have time to
look at it
but maybe 28 knight takes f3
i considered it but then takes i think
there's queen g2 in the end
the engine would know best
oops okay we're gonna play
i'll play a pierce
all right actually this is a modern so i
like to play this e5 line
and h3
knight g4 i think is kind of rare
what is this
take a free pawn looks free
nice looking position there's a line
um yeah i think i'm winning a piece
because it takes an e6
and the knights pin but there's also
potential for the
yeah the double attack
okay i can take with rook
um i have to be a little bit careful
[Music]
rook f6 is a threat
so maybe bishop g5 bishop g5 i lose b2
[Music]
how to do this
oh brook f6 is not a threat rook f6
queen d5
but it's still tricky
i'm gonna move quicker too just play
rook oh work b1 was a really bad move
okay i'm losing back a piece but
opponent's not seeing it
okay let's sack orc was trapped
basically
okay can take there
messy game so far but it's nice position
now
[Music]
just go for the queen trade
hmm
good try
okay wow that was close it's close
got low on time opponent had bishop
takes c3 at various moments but
i think my opponent was playing for time
too
so i'm oh i'm in second place let's go
i'm just trying to like win games
quickly i'll play um
play in knight t7 i usually play b6 but
um
this is also a playable line so going
for the bishop pair
um let's take in c6 queen c7
and b6
and a5 very positional line
i should know more theory here but this
is usually what people do
yeah b5 is a very confrontational move
um probably have to take and
and just roll with the punches
so a lot of pressure okay so we're going
to trade
um and there's 95 coming
how to do this if i take it with rook
white has to play a4 maybe that's the
way to go
and then put the rook on c1 oh but then
knight a7
so i'll play queen b7 first
and then roxy8
i really just want to fight for the the
file
okay here we could trade
yeah so now it's kind of like a french
structure the queen side is very
relevant
rook c4 and bishop b4 are maybe coming
there's some potential for light to
attack
f4 i'd probably play g6
just to slow down that five
okay this pawn is tender attack the
queen
always gotta watch out for this move but
bishop defends
and for the time being rook c4 is coming
throw in h6
online with the queen
so i'm trying to double up but also
kind of pressure the pawn could consider
taking
but there's no need
okay the double up has been accomplished
if i triple up i get forked
opponent wants to play queen d8
i could play queen e7
just try and simplify into a queenless
endgame
here york c2
queen g5 yeah getting a lot of activity
like the pieces are
really nicely placed
like white has more space in the center
but i'm able to play around the pawns
probably queen g4 here i don't want a
queen trade because i'm
i have a lot more attacking potential
i'd really like to expose this pawn
rookie two
okay yeah there's queen that f4 but i
take rook c2
here we go
so there's a really cool idea
but i'm not sure how to make it work
involves queen takes g3
to watch my time too
[Music]
you just bishop here attacking this pawn
oh i could have played uh some rook d2
move
d2 okay here i can take
i'm keeping all the tension
bishop g5 controlling c1 i'll start
pushing the h pawn
and bishop e3 there
oh i can't take
oh it's gonna be a time scramble
oh
let's go okay oh that was a tough game
i mean i like the way i played kind of
this
middle game but surely improving all the
pieces
and then it just came down to a time
scramble let's go
okay so i'm i'm within range of first
place
i have to catch up to the elephant pair
yeah a lot of uh a lot of the time
scrambles so far at least a few
okay playing narnia berserk can play d4
so i've lost i've lost one game
but now i'm on a streak opponent's
debating okay
opponent's not berserking
scramble bits oh thanks for the scramble
bits i appreciate that
to sends critic oh again with the two
senses
thanks so much
okay so we have we have a position black
is solid
but i'm also solid
things could get interesting soon with a
minor piece situation
h6 i probably probably have to go back
okay so queen c7 is to prepare this
i save the bishop and
oh okay i'll train
so black now has an isolated d-pawn at
the same time has a little bit more
activity
there's another f4 or bishop f4 but then
i'm probably happy to trade
uh in the meantime never mind
yeah so let's start by taking
and just allow
further training
i just want to play positioning against
the pawn
so the first step is to control the
blockading square
and then probably just to blockade it
and then put the rooks on the d-file
[Music]
and someday win the pawn
or just someday flag i guess we'll find
out
and time is leveling out like my
opponent's taking a lot of time
early on which is nice
take with rook
put the knight here so preventing bishop
f5
okay so this is basically my dream
scenario
just a question what do i do from here
maybe double up on the e-file or even
triple up
bishop d7
um
i probably should not have allowed that
yeah that didn't really help me in too
many ways
maneuver the knight maybe to f4
can actually attack the pawn and not get
in the way of the d-file
yeah i'm fine with the queen trade so
eventually i want to play c4 probably
right now
yeah this is the way you usually like
end up winning the pawn is taking
advantage of the pin
now there's four attackers only three
defenders
and g5 i take with knight
and knight on d5 will be very nice too
time is very nice calculating this and
then this
never mind everything's defended
queen defends backwards threatening some
kind of forced mate
okay gotta push them
yeah just improving the structure
oh there goes my pawn i work so hard to
win the pawn too
but i'm gonna win on time
hopefully okay there we go appointment
was fast
but i was faster let's go first place
first time first place in the tournament
actually i'm tied for first
elephant pair is paused i'm on the
street
let's go i haven't had a single staffer
gambit accepted this tournament
are we gonna see it never played george
oh it's a third staffer gamut declined
that's so sad
i'm so disappointed
i'll play this move cool move
so i'm kind of gambling upon
um
let's take it
do daily blitzes affect your rating
uh it affects my blitz rating
but not my other ratings not sure if i
answered your question with that
got my time spending too much time here
hey it's alright
thanks so much gifting subs welcome back
gifting five subs
i appreciate that play queen c7
yeah i really ought to manage my time
here
try and hold on to my my lead
a5 not sure what to do exactly
my king h8 and f6 getting off the
diagonal
[Music]
seeing some trades
probably gonna see more trades too but
c3 could be weak in the end
if white ever takes when i get the
bishop hair
that's a reasonable move
hmm i guess i'm giving away the bishop
here
gotta move a lot quicker
and g5 g5 might make some sense
just get the rook here
ah i blundered i'm gonna lose a pawn
[Music]
it's not so bad though because i
attacked this in the end
i have 14 seconds left man
okay threatening this
bishop f4 i can take with either thing
oh this is going to be unpleasant
oh it's orange giving gifting more subs
thanks so much
appreciate it
i'm in trouble though
in a lot of trouble
i'm gonna lose this unfortunately
ah three queens on the board in the
final position
good game i'm still in first though
and no one at least no one in the top
three has a streak
elephant is paused
i got too low on time there that's an
interesting end game though
so that's the second loss um
playing cole hoes zarya and thanks so
much again
alrich good to see you thank you hasaki
for the bits
no berserking this game
something about tagi oh
is talking to you finished watching your
london course last week i really enjoyed
it and have even
found similar tactics in my games thanks
oh very nice
speaking of london london time
i show this line in my course it's a
very typical structure
there's some cool ideas from this
variation
mainly b5 yeah taking advantage of the
pin
threatening the fork now
um oh wait let's not plunder a piece
knight c7
it's a question
question how i want to do this
knight c7 doesn't work debating knight
d6
or knight c3 i think i'll play knight c3
no let's play knight g6 get the bishop
here
94 is coming i want to play f3
g5 is not a bad move
yeah usually you want to keep the bishop
i wonder if i had any improvements there
okay um mean it's still a pleasant
position
some idea g4
like in general king d2 b4
[Music]
uh bishop d3 knight e2 that will be my
my main development scheme maybe knight
h3
could be a consideration or g4
let's go for b4 b5
yeah like this whole structure it's all
about creating weaknesses on the queen
side
black is defending though
the e5 is playable i think i'll start
with this move
so now if knight c6 i take and there's a
pin
now the e-file's open also the d-pawn's
a little bit weak
so knight c3 and rookie one will come
with some attack
and block's still defending threatening
rookie five
and i think after rookie five there's no
good way for
black to defend e4
oh bishop e6 coming
let's start with this and play f4
some idea to play f5 takes and then fork
and after takes takes i'm threatening
the pawn but also threatening f5 still
and now it's winning tactics are nice
really had to optimize like all the
pieces to to crack the position
but it works out
yeah all the locks pieces were like
purely defensive
okay black's probably going to try and
fight here
um
that still takes a little bit of work
put the rook here so preventing h3
now really preventing h3
i really want to play not f4 so
and probably king e3 to watch out for
the the rook coming in
making d3
just so if rook here i i can take and
then play knight c3 to defend
oh but then there's rook g3
i guess it's not happening okay now i
want to play rook f3
or maybe knight g1 to f3
i think i can take
yeah just trying to simplify
should be winning this pawn now
okay relatively clean game nice london
win opponent
uh point was stubborn with the defense
okay playing some weird name um
no berserking
gambit the first glue the best of the
the tournament
and play
one of the the main lines
yeah so i've played similar structures
many times before
white's playing well it's playing in the
style where it seems like they know what
they're doing
but i know what i'm doing
kind of yeah very typical budapest idea
it's usually why black delays playing
this move
until now
and thanks for subbing antique ram
subbing with prime
yeah there's all these potential
sacrifices
and question how to make them work
how to make something work you can start
with queen h4
i mean all the pieces ready to attack in
various ways
one of the issues if knight g3 takes
takes takes there's queen g2
so i'm considering after knight g3
playing this move to prepare this
hi hello and hey hope your day is going
well eric
oh yeah thanks it's going well so far
trying to calculate bishop g7 takes and
then bishop c6 and takes
okay i lose two pawns
oh but then i take on g2
and now the knight of five shouldn't
hurt me
i don't think
so i have two pawns hanging potentially
losing
a lot of the queen side pawns but
white's not interested
i mean this is a consideration
[Music]
it's crazy hey chat what is your
favorite thing about
eric and his content oh i guess i don't
have to answer that
i gotta focus on the game that's a
wholesome question
so knight g4 queen f4
and then g5
and then queen here
um it's confusing wait can i win a pawn
takes takes free pawn
i was so fixated on attacking that
sometimes it's hard to
to spot free pawns so i'm just
unleashing the rook
attacking the knight
that's a move yeah that's what we call a
desperado
but i'm still winning a pawn
i can put the rook here threading h3
i just gotta watch my time
there's no f3 because e3 is loose
there's a cool line rook g1 rook here
rook or bishop here
saying oh no my rook i play here i lose
a rook and i
mate
oh no my rook oh no
[Music]
opponent sees it though it's unfortunate
yeah i tried
that's a cool idea
i guess i'll play this move because now
the plans to play
d5 and then bishop d6 just trying to
provoke g3
i'm realizing it's maybe not so simple
though my rooks get could
kind of get stuck on the king's side
hmm
i always have to be aware of this move
too
f4 is a good move
play bishop here aiming towards the pawn
yeah the rooks are actually like they've
kind of committed themselves to the h
file
and now it's just kind of weird bishop
e1 coming
how bad is this play f4
or f5 string one rook
kind of move a lot quicker
probably c5 coming
that's complicated
oh that's a good move i'm in trouble i
have this move
no
i've lost on time oh that was a nice
position too
somehow i'm still oh no i'm not in for
oh oh i lost a
oh that was a crucial game i should have
maybe not
lost but now it's too late so much
regret uh
no berserking
oh yeah we we had the london game
previously the banner before each game
says stand by americrosen
oh yeah standby i don't think i realized
that or maybe i did
okay so i have to have to get on the
streak again
h6 yeah i had this earlier
had the same line earlier
i think my plan is to bring the knight
to h5
through the first trimester hey three
months
let's go thank you gelatinous cube
i appreciate it okay
so yeah we played like the sec i think
the second game of the tournament for me
so i'm trying to be tricky okay that's a
free pawn
oh nothing in life is free
and def d5 is actually kind of a cool
move
queen b4 also
[Music]
play queen here just going for the the
kill
maybe this was trickier to
pressure c7
oh no my rook
okay so i can check maybe bring the
this rook in it's it's close to just
completely winning but it's not entirely
clear
okay
there's a cool line where i i sack
everything and then mate
what does that move so i wanted to do
this and then this and then this but
there's my t5
i think i'll start with rook c3
okay now i can take here we go
yeah the tactics really um
become clear here both sides of the
board are connected
it's sometimes easy to forget the the
queen side is connected to the king's
side
oh but it's still not over except it is
yeah it's nice uh oh hey bishop is
pinned to the
meeting square
wait i could have done that right away
that's funny i i should have done
that was made in two but this was more
pretty
with the double rook sack okay
so trying to get back on a streak
also trying to break twenty five hundred
also thank you mo sg subbing for 13
months
really appreciate it
so this could be close
berserk and go for a budapest
okay budapest declined a lot of people
declining gambits today
that was tricky
go play 94
um
and there's i want to do fun things but
let's just take
and this is looking pretty good already
a queen g5
oh
i'm going to avoid taking because then
it's probably easier to play for white
after rook g1
okay gonna put the pawn
far into white's territory
[Music]
how to do this
maybe bishop b6 and then knight c5
yeah the knight is better than the
bishop here
if i get the chance i want to play e4
probably
i have to defend that
takes takes i think this is playable
[Music]
and it's a trade but i open the file
now the f pawn's attacked
and now the the queen is coordinating
with a rook
take another pawn
oh i allowed work age one i forgot h7
was attacked
but opponent didn't punish me
still tricky so ideas after it takes
i should have considered rook f2 there
but if takes i have queen e5
okay
gotta move a lot quicker
work here not sure what my plan is
to put the rook somewhere oh here we go
the plan is not to flag
plan is also to promote a pawn
okay got the job done no time to waste
still trying to catch up to to first
place
yeah i got pretty low on time that game
oh i forgot i made more tea won't see
here
a big pot of green tea
oh playing first place okay this is very
important game
london time
london versus slav gg oh gg thanks for
that
yeah i gotta stay focused
so i had a similar position earlier do
we play the same
i forget i guess not
i played a similar line against a
different opponent earlier
it's a fun line half open a file more
space
if e5 i'll play bishop g3
yeah usually people have the knight on
f6 already
but not the case here so i want to play
this and just
make the pawn move
just so the diagonal is unleashed
um resourceful
play this move and go for b4
that's going to be a tense position but
i have a nice time advantage
i think currently i'm threatening to
take and after takes rook a6
i mean one of the issues with the pawn
here is that i'm not controlling these
squares
so the rooks can sometimes be more
useful defending on
on one of the dark squares but for now
the rooks tie down to the
a pawn
wow i don't think i've been up a minute
on the clock this whole tournament
okay now i'm threatening to win the pawn
probably
the knights pinned three attackers
but if i take never mind
okay so probably want to play b4 here
i'm just reinforcing okay now i could
take and win the pawn
um yeah why not
i'm realizing even if i win my opponent
will still be ahead of me
which is kind of sad so i'm going to
just try and win quickly
i should probably castle get the rook oh
never mind
i wanted to castle okay here my pawn
goes marching
a funny position now
okay i want to play f3 i also want to
take the bishop
can't play f3 just yet because e3 would
hang
but oh did i trap the bishop
i think i trapped the bishop bishop here
i play this there's bishop f5
but then f3 e4 may be
in such a weird position opponent forgot
rooks move sideways
okay
yeah there was 95
the harmony is really nice here
play this move
just preserve the bishop
rook g1 probably wasn't necessary but it
looks fun
attacking the bishop oh
okay now attacking both bishops
okay i'm just going for the flag or the
meat
or the windmill
where's my meat is this move
there we go okay so
i got four points for that tied for
seconds
we're approaching maybe the last game or
two let's dessert and let's play d4
maybe i should have played e4
we're gonna have a london probably the
same opening
well a lot of people playing this today
yeah by the time uh the trade happens on
b3 it's
it's pleasant for whites but
as have we seen as we've seen in the
previous games
it can be a positional grind
i think i want to go for the b7 pawn
sometimes i should include this move
just like some knight h5
or not
hmm trying to figure out how i crack the
queen side
so it's not so intuitive
i might have to crack the center like e4
at some point
or maybe i'll maneuver my knight to c3
man so to win the tournament i probably
have to win this game then win another
game
it's gonna be tough
here we go so the the whole plans to
play b5 now
taking advantage of the pin here's how
i'm breaking through
[Music]
now c6 may be coming i'm trying to get a
mating attack with
just some minor pieces basically it's
kind of working
i got all the pieces involved now
knight c5
just trying to put maximum pressure
attacking the knight and the bishop oh
it's a
double attack
i just want one more okay let's go one
more game hey first place
i got berserking point so i got five
points
and second place is no longer on the
street because i i
beat them in the previous game so let's
berserk and this will be the final game
staffer gambit time come on i haven't
had the stafford accepted the whole
tournament
let's go stafford gav is accepted
oh and it's this line let's go
this is what happens when they accept
the stafford it's so much fun
let's go while the way to end the
tournament
i think kimi 7 is uh is king 7 the
playable move
i think it is because the queen's still
attacked
and i i didn't want to take and allow my
knight to get pinned
and it still may be a little bit tricky
but this is uh this is so nice
oh that's a tricky move
wait i haven't seen this one before
wait a minute
i can't celebrate too early
did i mess us up queen g3
queen g3 is probably the way to go
wait a minute takes
how do i do this or maybe it takes here
bishop d king h2 bishop d6
opponent tricked me in like a weird
that's a weird line
i i may have celebrated too early there
i think it's still winning though
because e5
oh no i messed this up
i messed it up i'm losing a piece
i can't take the bishop
oh please hold on to first place though
also i'm i'm gonna flag probably yeah
i have to check this line after opponent
was very resourceful there
okay b5 i'm still fighting though
hello youtube yeah
it's kind of embarrassing to lose
in the stafford line but i'm still
fighting
um
um there goes my position
but i guess it doesn't count for the
tournament
ah hey i won the tournament
let's go what a weird ending
so i finally got a stafford exception
opponent walked into like the
losing position but then tricked me
oh thanks for that i appreciate it yeah
thanks for all the love and support
from everyone congrats
so that that game did not officially
count for the tournament
um i really have to analyze that
yes eric yes yes yes
yes what does yasu say
yes yes
celebratory bits oh yeah the celebratory
bits
thanks everyone so many celebratory 100
bits
with so many people cheering bits
so i'm not sure whether to be
disappointed like i waited the whole
tournament to get the stafford accepted
i got it okay let's check the game yeah
let's go
so i performed above my reading task
field successfully
yeah it's not easy to perform above my
rating when i berserk so much
but it worked out
um let's check this game
thanks everyone i really appreciate it
so
um i get i get tweets and like dms all
the time
from people saying like they're getting
this as black and they're winning really
quickly
a lot of people play queen f3 here
and then black is force meaning
oh thanks for the performance bits so
usually what happens is like this
is this mate bishop f7
i know is a move i assumed king e7 is
still
winning oh
engine says king d8 i'm not sure what
the difference is so king d
queen h5
oh i can take on e4 and then have access
to g3
but still king h2
so takes on e4 if king h2 i play queen
g3
ah bishop d6 here
so i don't go for knight f2 because okay
my king's in danger
but now it's winning and white has to
sack the queen
and if d4 so i didn't go for knight here
because d4 is scary because then bishop
g5 is an idea
but apparently this is still winning
bishop e5
oh okay so white's getting material
but black is black is up a queen
for rook and bishop
actually queen and pawn for rook and
bishop and has some initiative
oh night chief oh the line keeps going
here here
here here rook ae1 king d8
at such a long line
okay but eventually things simplify
so okay now i know um
yeah very so very very few people
what's the right word very few people
will play bishop c4 and then be able to
find like this
very resourceful bishop f7 queen h5
um yeah because king takes f7
then white's better after d4
okay so if this goes on youtube
thanks people watching on youtube
the future people um yeah twitch chat
has been so supportive
uh youtube people say hi to twitch chat
and twitch chat say hi to youtube engine
recommended kd8 instead of k7
oh that's also true yeah i should
investigate further
but more priorities for now hello to
youtube
my child is so friendly